حجم 6.1 بوصة الشهير لـ iphone
14 ينضم إليه الحجم الجديد الأكبر بحجم 6.7 بوصة
من iphone 14 بالإضافة إلى
أنه يحتوي على كاميرا رئيسية جديدة بدقة 12 ميجابكسل
مع مستشعر أكبر وبكسلات أكبر
عند 1.9 ميكرون وهذا وضع الحركة
يستخدم المستشعر الكامل مع المزيد
المسح الزائد وتصحيح التدوير المتقدم
لجعل الفيديو يبدو مستقرًا بشكل لا يصدق
عندما تكون في منتصف الحدث ،
لقد أدخلنا أيضًا تحسينات كبيرة على
التقنيات الخلوية مثل esim مما
يجعل الاتصال أسهل ، كما أن esim عبارة عن
شريحة رقمية تقضي على الحاجة  بالنسبة
لبطاقة sim الفعلية بينما تم
تصميم iPhone للحصول على أفضل تجربة خلوية في فئتها ، فإن
الاتصال بالقمر الصناعي
يقدم مجموعة جديدة تمامًا من
التحديات التي صممناها وصنعناها
مكونات مخصصة وبرامج محددة حتى
تتمكن هوائيات iphone 14 من الاتصال
بالترددات الفريدة للأقمار الصناعية التي تأتي
بخمسة ألوان رائعة ، يبدأ iPhone 14
بسعر 7.99 فقط
، بينما يبدأ سعر iphone 14 plus من 8.99 فقط
، ويأتي بأربعة ألوان رائعة
، وفضي أسود جديد.
ld وهذا اللون الأرجواني الغامق الجديد تمامًا ،
لذلك الآن عندما تتلقى تنبيهًا ،
تتوسع الجزيرة الديناميكية لإعلامك بأن
هذا يعمل عبر النظام بأكمله
لأشياء مثل التأكد من أن أجهزة airpods الخاصة بك متصلة بكتم الصوت
أو بدء الشحن ،
فإن شاشة القفل الجديدة في نظام التشغيل iOS 16 تقدم
المزيد من التخصيص  باستخدام الأدوات والأنشطة الحية ،
يمكنك الآن تصوير صور
احترافية بدقة 48 ميجابكسل
مع الاستفادة من كل بكسل في
الكاميرا الرئيسية وإلغاء تأمين مرونة تحرير مذهلة ، لا
يزال iPhone 14 pro يبدأ عند
9.99 و iphone 14 pro max بسرعة 10.99 مع
خيارات تخزين تصل إلى واحد تيرابايت
[موسيقى]